the strangers prey at night is the
sequel to the first film that came out
in 2008 starring Liv Tyler and this film
is once again about three masked killers
who seem to be killing for no reason at
all this time they've targeted a family
that's in a deserted trailer park mom
dad and brother and sister and over the
course of 85 minutes we watch all four
of them flee from these killers and try
to escape from their monotonous attempts
at death this film was not good
the first strangers I think is a pretty
joyful slasher movie it's not great but
there was something unhinged about that
movie that was unnerving and I liked the
direction bryan bertino I believe was
his name he chose to do a lot of
Steadicam and handheld stuff with that
movie and so a lot of shots felt just
like there was more work behind it than
your average slasher so when we get to
the sequel that's coming out 10 years
later this is directed by the guy who
brought us 47 meters down so that you
know I mean is this is yet another
carpenter s horror film this feels like
a movie that John Carpenter may have
made in the 80s except without the style
and without any of the flair for real
scares it has everything that carpenter
liked a victim running through a
deserted neighborhood in the middle of
the night while a killer stalks them
very slowly while somehow also catching
up and a lot of sequences like that over
and over again and this movie doesn't
have anything new to bring to the table
it's also not really a sequel that
connects itself to the first in any way
except for the fact that we have three
masked killers that look the same
there's no attempt to bridge the gap it
feels like one of those direct-to-dvd
sequels like open water 3 or wrong turn
6 that has no real connection to the
first film it's just a property now so
let's try to make it again also
following in John Carpenter's footsteps
is the 80s synth score it sounds so much
like john carpenter's work on the fog i
mean i couldn't help but hear it it
sounded just like his piano theme for
that film and that was something that
bugged me too and following in the steps
of
be Hooper the director of Texas Chainsaw
Massacre there's a shot towards the
third act in a sequence that is so
similar to that film that I saw it my
buddy philippic and we actually turn to
each other and just said out loud Texas
Chainsaw Massacre
we were whispering but it was just so
obvious and I don't really understand
what the point is here are they making
an homage because if it's trying to be
an homage or a tribute it just comes off
like a ripoff when it comes to horror
films like this where the characters are
trapped in one location there are
certain devices that could end the movie
a phone a gun access to a working
vehicle things like that without those
things you're trapped and with those
things the movies over throughout the
film characters get access to all three
of these things and you know for a fact
it's nothing's gonna happen and the
characters are so incredibly stupid that
whenever they get a hold of one of these
items they find a way to get rid of it
really fast and one of my biggest issues
with this film directly relates to that
and that's the villains in the first
movie they were just these crazy people
that tried to kill Liv Tyler and Scott
Speedman in this movie they kind of come
off like super villains it's one of the
big problems with the worst James Bond
movies James Bond's not a superhero he's
just a guy with some skills he's not a
superhero the worst Bond films treat him
like he is same with Jason Bourne Jason
Bourne is not a superhero he's just
somebody who's very skilled the second
you elevate him to superhero level those
films are no longer as interesting or as
grounded that's a major problem with
prey at night the bad guys survive
things that would kill any person they
somehow know whenever the hero gets a
gun or a phone or a working vehicle it's
like they have 10,000 security cameras
at this deserted trailer park and know
every single move and the second one of
the characters gets a device that could
end the film they know exactly where to
go and as I said they survived so many
things it's just so hilarious at some
point the film does get unexpectedly
funny there
Vann seen many audience members were
laughing during this van scene somebody
gets injured and it just they drag it on
and on and you could tell that the
filmmakers thought wow this is such a
scary moment but it was so poorly acted
and so poorly conceived as a horror
scene that it was just funny that's
another thing the four main characters
they didn't seem to know which ones were
the most interesting because the ones
they chose to focus the most on were
perhaps the least interesting characters
and because of that the film just got
kind of boring after a while and very
monotonous there's only so many times
you can watch somebody almost die almost
get a hold of a gun a phone or a car and
then lose that and then run away while
screaming and crying and a succession of
scenes like that over and over again it
just it gets boring I wasn't expecting
anything amazing out of this film I'm a
huge fan of horror movies and I love a
good slasher movie and I will watch
cheesy slashers I owned tons of them but
this film had some atmospheric shots and
it had a few effective scenes there's a
scene in a pool really good stuff that
was probably the best scene in the movie
but there's so many dumb choices these
characters make and somehow they
inexplicably keep losing access to
things that could save their lives
because they just don't give a
about their home fires I guess but in
reality we know that it's really the
people behind the film who are trying to
figure out how they can get this thing
to ninety minutes at least and to do
that they have to keep these characters
in this tiny deserted trailer park where
nobody apparently lives except for these
three Psychopaths from the first
strangers who I guess now in the present
day ten years later are just hanging out
on some deserted trailer park doing
nothing what's the connection to the
first one this film actually got under
my skin more than I thought it would and
not in the the way I expected to I'm not
like a die-hard fan of the first
strangers but I know there are a lot of
fans out there that are and they're
gonna be disappointed when they see just
some throwaway straight-to-dvd slasher
movie that's masquerading as a sequel to
a cult slasher film that a lot of people
like
this movie could have just been a fun
slasher movie and that's exactly what it
should have been it has some okay
effective moments but it doesn't know
which characters to focus on it has an
overabundance of stupid idiotic
character choices and it doesn't really
know how to be all that scary the
tension isn't as real as it could have
been the setup is okay but once the
first scene happens where you're like
okay now we're in the thick of it the
movie just becomes a run away from
somebody with a knife movie for the next
hour I'm gonna give the strangers prey
at night a D it also has a very silly
ending it's one of the first times in a
while that I've outloud said what when
the screen goes black it was so stupid
this movie was disappointing guys what
did you think of this film if you saw it
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen heist
[Music]